so when it relates to to the left right
now I assume you're basically someone
that comes from the left right I mean
from everything I know you a classical
liberal in every every virtually every
sense yeah so I assume then also that
you feel the same way I do that it's
your job to police them more than the
right right like for me people always
say to me well why aren't you attacking
the right as much and it's like I'm not
part of the right I do attack them I
know I don't think I've ever voted for a
Republican in my life not I'm not a fan
of the Democrats and uh and I'm not a
Democrat I'm an independent but I but
for me to police the people that I'm not
part of you know it just seems silly I
want to police my guys do you feel that
I mean is that part of what you do and I
feel to me it's more germane in the
sense that the left the regressives have
taken over academia they have literally
hijacked the institutions and now
they're institutionalizing these
policies which are really rather extreme
by any and any any classical liberal
would be horrified at what their speech
codes microaggressions trigger one it's
horrifying yeah and they're basically
robbing a generation of people of the
possibility of being able to think
clearly and critically and their ever
increasing the threshold people's
threshold for what they consider to be
offensive or the types of conversations
they'll have is continuously dropping so
for me it's personal only and then I
have to deal with this every single day
and I write I mean it is the most
personal thing yeah it's it's endemic
now why don't you criticize the right as
much well I mean look I have criticized
the right you've criticized the right
think about the type of criticism you
have to label against a guy who is a
bonafide
can I swear on your show where away yeah
everyone always asked me before they
swear a problem I promise that asked
before that's why that's fine yeah I
mean think of think about about you know
like Huckabee who's a bona fide [ __ ]
lunatic yeah right I mean think about
guys like Donald Trump I mean these guys
are so outside not even the may actually
that's studies they're not outside the
mainstream or at least of that place
yeah and labeling a sort of criticism
against that type of crazy is very
different from people for whom I feel
sympathies for these impulses they have
they have very decent impulses at base
and we need to be careful that because
they're so insincere and dishonest that
we don't disregard their whole message
like we the onus falls upon us to think
clearly about that into really okay
privilege I got it you know
this gender thing you know but to really
take a step back and separate the
message from the messenger so that we
don't discount the whole thing yeah and
I'm very very aware of that all the time
you know because I know that I'm
attacking the trigger warnings in the
safe space and all that stuff and I
don't want to throw the baby out with
the bathwater and I know that there are
legitimate racial issues and I really
JIT omit socio-economic issues and all
of that stuff but because of the way
these guys have behaved and framed the
debate they've made it extremely
difficult to separate legitimate issues
that's exactly right from pure craziness
so I think what's interesting related to
someone like you that comes from a place
where you're writing and talking about
moral clarity and critical thinking this
has to be it's almost like doubly worse
for you in a way to to be part of this
because there's the there's the thinking
part there's the spiritual part like
it's just a lot mixed into one crazy
thing yeah it's interesting I mean
everybody you had I think Nick Cohen on
here and other people have given
genealogical accounts of how we got into
the situation but I think the thing that
people really aren't thinking about are
talking about that much or what are the
implications for these things I mean
what are the philosophical what does
this mean what did this would I notice
we're both speaking quickly we have so
much a second how much to get out what
does this mean when we've created
academic environments in which people in
which professors are terrified to given
a dissenting opinion and in but
dissenting I mean something from from
the regressive party line right what is
that mean just for a sec let's define
dissenting because it's barely
dissenting it's literally just saying
anything other yeah descending it's not
like you're saying something that's
really against what the mainstream
believe is it's pretty much anything
like
you know be okay with someone else
wearing a Halloween costume that you may
not like that's the tort sort of
dissenting we're talking and that's the
kind of craziness that you get when I
mean so it's again the issue of how we
got there is extremely interesting and
valuable I'm I'm interested in recently
my work has been focusing on what does
that mean for one's intellectual life
like what does that mean for one's
ability to reflect on issues what does
that mean for one's ability to make
decisions about things that really
matter not Halloween costumes I
understand that some people think that
matters but that's just evidence of an
inability to show moral triage you know
- prior to indexical you prioritize
prior to some kind of a hierarchy -
identified it one need as an another
need and show why that's important and
the way that you do that is through
reason and rationality that's how you
get there and the way that you so when
you attack safe spaces when you attract
true mornings you're actually this is
the key thing you're actually doing them
a favor because because you're giving
them an opportunity you're giving people
an opportunity if their values are true
like if their values are morally correct
and I do believe there's such a thing as
being morally correct and obviously they
do as well or they couldn't be espousing
and that's just parenthetically that's
the interesting difference between
that's the the the contradiction in
their beliefs between being lost my
train of thought well that I think I
think you're going that they think that
yeah so right yeah so so you so these
people they have the legacy of
relativism but yet the values that they
put forth a radical egalitarianism you
cannot be a relativist enemy galat area
etc you cannot say everything is
relative and then all systems are equal
so one of the things that you're doing
what you're doing they'll look at it as
to them but I will look at it as to
advance their cause yeah one of the
things you're doing is you're giving
people an opportunity to reflect on how
they know what they know and the only
way you can do that
is through an unsafe space the only way
you can do that is to really take a look
at these ideas and examine these ideas
there just is no other way so if they
have their values are arbitrary and
subject to cultural capriciousness
unless they can be rationally derived
and they have taken out the engine of
rationality once they've created spaces
in which you can't ask these questions
yeah so that's why I a few times I'll
say that the road to hell is paved with
good intentions that these guys actually
Joe Rogan fought me on this when I said
this I said I believe these guys like
with the Affleck thing on real time with
Sam Harris and all that I said well his
intentions were good you know I mean he
was intending to try to protect the
other Joe basically was like now he's a
Hollywood guy and then he's just
protecting his own own internals an
actor he's an actor that's it he's he's
out for number one fine but I guess
that's probably what really is perverse
about what's going on on the left
because by taking kids by taking college
kids whose thoughts aren't fully
formulated yet and then putting this
thing on them they think they're doing
everything for good intentions but then
they're gonna walk out into the world
realizing the world doesn't really react
that way and if they're listening to
this and they're just dumping on you and
hating you and hating me
I think it's perhaps a nice helpful
heuristic to think about it in terms of
standing for the flag an example on the
right though people on the right are big
on that your respect for the flag
they've made their own things sacred but
I don't think that's important I think
what's important is to teach people why
they should stand for the flag what our
values mean and and that's why they're
standing it's not an icon but I think
that the same property holds on the left
they have to they have to start being
honest and realizing that if their
values really are true then they have to
subject those values to scrutiny then we
have to create spaces we have to create
environments where the marketplace of
ideas we can have a discourse and a
dialectic
exactly that's just a little different
we might just do the clue the opera
birth that's why they should be thanking
you
yeah I mean I'm being facetious I'm
being a sincere that's why they should
be thanking you because if not then that
means their values are arbitrary so when
I talked about this with Milo and the
college thing you know he said that what
this really is about this isn't about
left and right he was saying that this
really is about authoritarians
versus that's the root of Moshe and
that's what you're really talking that's
the horseshoe yeah so so somehow though
I think this is related to to religion
too right we can relate this very much
to absolutely the thinking of religion
so can you go down that path for me a
little bit yes so they use many of the
same mechanisms they have things that
are sacred in this case it's the rise of
the victim the victim hood culture they
have certain questions certain ideas
can't be questions can't be challenged
the churches are safe spaced University
campuses are safe space and and so
here's what's super interesting when I
did a talk a few years ago I don't know
five years I don't even know it's on you
to Jesus the Easter Bunny and other
delusions just say no yeah I know if you
saw that or not doesn't matter but but
the people who protested that were not
Christians I had some Christians come in
the audience I speak all around the
world people are in general with very
few exceptions Christians and Muslims
are very civil the Christians I go out
for a beer off and after it but it's the
regressive leftist who I mean this I
mean really think about this this is
just as like the the feminist is where I
said to Joe today it's like the
feminists in bed with the Islamists it
means you just could not conceive of a
relationship that was more antithetical
to one one of those parties interests
right so so it's interesting that that
and I'm pretty sure that the the
Islamists know that they're never going
to treat these women any better right so
what is that what is that I'm sorry to
cut you off but what is that that what
are they doing so they just view so
these feminists for whatever they just
view the other as more oppressed than
they are so they just have to give them
their credit mean is that really that
simple that is a comp I have thought
about that a long time I think it deals
with the color of people's skin
oppression I think it deals with you
know this whole
third wave feminism that I still don't
understand I don't know I don't I cannot
explain to you and I've thought about it
extensively how this cohabitation find
not a marriage but how this how this
bizarre relationship came to be I still
cannot understand it and the most recent
event at Goldsmiths the Dawkins was
tweeting on and such I mean that is that
should be a case study for people the
that is even boggling my mind to even
think about trying to understand that
right and then so that and and all of
this and all the stuff that we're
talking about in this discussion it
shows again why that if you don't help
the Reformers the actual reformers who
are trying to change make things better
for women and gays in my own question
you don't help these people and you keep
framing these people as the problem
right well what do you do you get the
rise of Trump yeah yeah I'm just gonna
say the extreme I think my treat was
something like if you have create
environments in which you can't ask
questions extremists step in with
solutions and I think that's exactly
right
could this so really could do you think
that this atmosphere that that Trump is
taken advantage of there there a sense a
palpable fear okay in America that I
haven't felt before yeah I really do I
sense that people are feeling like
everything is screwed up that there's we
have this terrorism stuff we don't know
what the answers are there's this
refugee thing we're all children of
refugees or descendants of refugees here
unless you came over as a slave or
American Indian right if you were
actually indigenous to this land and I
just have the sense that people don't
know what's going on and then when you
shut down the people on the last exactly
better try then of course Trump yeah
okay so I really wish that every single
person listening to that would put the
rewind button and listen to that again
so if you're one of these people who
thinks that you're doing the world a
favor by creating you know triggering
protecting people who are you know you
want to protect the sensitivities of
others again not a bad impulse at all
but the consequence of that is that
people become less capable of making
discerning rational
particularly in the moral sphere so the
consequence of those things is that
Donald Trump is right there with the
answer and I just read a piece about the
number of people who who support Trump
who won't admit it is far higher which
is terrifying and we know that the way
we don't want to create a visceral
relationships
I mean if so I think the part of this
problem I don't want to go down this
rabbit hole necessarily the part of this
problem is we have to engage Trump's
arguments on his own terms and part of
that is if the idea is that that this is
going to make America safer I think
that's what we should we shouldn't
appeal the Patriots image we should take
a look at that I don't think that claim
is true I don't think that's borne out
by the evidence I don't think there's
any reason to think that first off its
not even constitutional any of the
keeping people out based on religion or
we can't we can accept we can just
bracket that yeah and we can just look
at okay what is the consequences of this
and you know what is the cons well let's
see well what is the content you think
that Muslim Muslim Islamic again so we
need to do whatever getting caught in
words even this isn't that the crazy
thing yeah they've made us all so crazy
about words that whatever you were about
to say there you had to think about it
18 different ways even though you're
sitting across from somebody that you
know is okay with the idea of what
you're gonna talk yeah I was I was
caught because I said okay well we
should have defined the terms in Islam
is the religion the belief the ideas so
and and mother from the people rose
those are the people and it for some
reason that seems to be an unbelievably
- way too complicated for people - um I
don't understand why do you think that
is because and it also seems like they
can only do that with Islam like the
issue only seems to be with Islam
because if we were to say anything about
Christianity would be saying great job
baby my eyes are awesome all day long or
if you say anything about radical Islam
they'll say well the Crusades and which
is hot right right so that so you did it
okay so that's right because that's
remember I said the values they holder
yell turn ism relativism for them in
their minds egalitarians look every age
has had a dominating value and Aristotle
talks about the Aristotelian gentleman
in Homer it was strengthened Volterra
was humor
now it's it's in one side it's
egalitarianism and relativism for for
them everything has to be relatives like
the the usually the default is
relativistic and and egalitarian so well
they have their bad guys but you have
your bad guys I'm actually not actually
those things are not morally equivalent
and so so you ask the question which is
pertinent and it want it's one that
should be explored like what is that
about I think part of it is that we've
extended the the umbrella of rights
wider and wider and I want to be crystal
clear that I'm I'm being descriptive and
not evaluative I'm describing the state
I'm not saying it's good or bad you know
I was just at a restaurant with my buddy
there before we came here and you know I
don't eat I try to eat only cruelty-free
meat so I won't eat it's cool so we've
now extended the umbrella of rights to
animals right
so that is constantly extending so the
next step for some people is to extend
that to ideas we've extended that and I
and I think that's really interesting
right you got it
yeah our struggle hello I want to sort
of get in that for a second so we've
extended the ideas of rights which used
to be for people now to animals because
we want to treat animals better minority
the next version of that will be with
ideas yeah we're gonna sort of take
we're gonna put on even softer gloves
when it comes to ideas because even that
should be held in some sort of that
because people as I said in my Tam talk
ideas don't deserve dignity people do
and it's kind of become a mean but it's
true it's it's that it's just the next
kind of radical taking that idea and
extending it further on yeah and the
problem with that is that you do a
disservice to those people holding
beliefs because you don't respect their
beliefs to engage them enough let's see
the thing that's really not talked about
this whole enterprise is really one of
disrespect that they're trying to
engender these values of respect but not
listening to people not engaging people
people's ideas even you know you've
talked about ensure the soft bigotry of
low expectations I think it was Bush's
phrase
and I kept crediting bill Mahr which at
least sounded nice now I'm quoting
George W Bush I don't know how I feel
well I don't know so then you'll pay me
a con right there are many how
everybody's gonna gang up on us because
they're gonna say look at you guys you
really love bush deep in your heart
ya know that's actually not true that's
just a fabrication that's the kind of
mental gymnastics people need to do to
keep their ideological biases in place
yeah well that was one of the things you
know when we launched the show a Nora
Sam was the first guest and he said that
they're always looking that these people
are always looking for something in you
not that you've said this opinion or
that you've shared this idea but if they
can somehow link together something that
gets them to where they want you to be
you're out yeah and just think about
this kind of person think about
discharging that impulse that you have
think about the kind of person that you
are you know it's difficult for me to
say without without being overly harsh
and it's an example of time when someone
ought to be overly harsh but that makes
me feel really sad for somebody yeah
well that's that's it very much how I
feel out of all of this because look I
can barely speak when I'm saying it
because this this situation has cost me
friends and relationships already and
I've only been talking about this stuff
for a couple months and so when I see
the way people have turned on me and I
I've gotten into bit debates with
friends and said can you point me to
where I said what you're accusing me up
yeah and they never do because they
can't so that's it that so if I may ask
you it what is the point of contention
you lost friends was that an issue was
it a sweet over someone who exists in
the world that we exist in that's a
public person who I no longer talked to
anymore who's been a good friend of mine
for last couple years said that my whole
show now is about bigotry to Muslims and
I said it's actually the complete answer
I'm trying to separate people from the
ideology I'm trying to show that not
everyone believes this I brought on
people repeatedly to talk about
tolerance right you know the way they'll
frame they'll say Sam and Maajid that
there
that these are the bigots their book was
about Islamic literature of Tolerance
not Islam in the future of nuclear war
you know so it sees mental gymnastics as
you just said so what would that person
like you to do not talk about it I
suppose not talk about these important
issues okay but but I'm not going to do
that that right but then again that that
goes back to what we started the
conversation with then that's why you
get trumps yeah exactly so I don't I
would ask them so that's kind of the de
feasibility test that I talked about in
the book and the app has the
diffusability test it's under what
conditions do you think that that belief
would be false yeah you can leave you
just have to be religion you can use the
de feasibility test it's not my idea
it's Matt McCormick's you can use the de
feasibility test with anything so under
what conditions could I demonstrate to
you that I am NOT a bias against Muslims
i dro if they say to you well there are
no conditions well that's a type of
belief closure there's then there's
there there almost is no conversation
then you have to take a step back and I
hate to say this but to the metal level
and have a conversation about that right
but but I think that I don't know I'm
now numb kind of I da ting I think I'm
like concern about your friendship with
this product
I mean I'd give it up basically because
once because after being called a bigot
repeatedly and saying actually no and
can you point me to any I know I'm not a
bigot
you know Douglas Murray said something
really interesting on Sam's podcast he
said I have no time anymore for people
whose intentions are not good you know
what I mean so I know I'm not a racist
so if you want to call me a racist or
call me a bigot it actually since I'm
not it actually I don't like being
called a racist or a bigot but it
doesn't really have any meaning because
it's just a word if I was secretly a
racist and you were calling me a racist
I suppose I would struggle with it a
little bit more but I'm so that's that's
the hard thing about that's that really
is difficult about dealing with people
who are insincere and I think a lot of
those attacks on Sam like I in
philosophy this thing called a
hermeneutic of charity you want to give
everybody a chart about reputation and
you want to say okay these guys actually
believe this stuff you know but over
time you just have to grow up yeah I
mean I I hate to say this I mean I don't
hate to say this because it's
ah I should have woken up to this
conclusion long ago I don't think these
people are sincere no I don't think so
at all but that's hard to grasp - it is
hard to grasp because if they thought
they had the truth why wouldn't they be
sincere yeah so she's me that's that's
thing that kind of keeps me from going
on a full-throttle attack I mean maybe
their cognitive software is somehow been
hijacked by this moral this idea that
they think that they're defending the
downtrodden and you know this you know
we need to do this as an example it's
okay to do this because we're serving
some you know there's some utilitarian
calculus like oh it's going to be in the
greater good I don't know what goes
through their minds but that's the
problem with dealing with someone who's
insincere yeah so I do think that I
think that they think and maybe I'm
probably giving them the the leash that
they wouldn't afford me right but I do
think they think as Margit said he he
said they think that they're in a war so
they're going to use whatever tactics
they have what I find particularly odd
about it is that now that we live in a
digital age where everything is recorded
and you can be quoted you know talking
to this person about this or this person
about that even when they're confronted
with new evidence or confronted or
exposed as frauds they just double down
even more which is incredible yeah so so
I share your frustration and I'm
sympathetic with it I don't know I would
I would I mean on a Hey look I you know
I'm just I'd call your friend again and
say hey look I've been thinking about
this let's have a talk I mean I wouldn't
let that friendship go because that's
not I tried to get them to sit down we
did this over text they wouldn't even
know okay I mean they wouldn't even see
a copy but that's that's again part of
the regressive left do i they don't want
to have conversations they want to end
those conversations and ironically they
turn that against us and say well look
you guys are the ones who don't want to
have conversations and look the whole
problem this is the schism and
liberalism right and it was made can
naked on the Bill Maher show with Ben
Affleck and Sam and this is something
again to solve these problems we need to
be on it we need to be forthright we
need to be
we need to create environments where we
can talk about the problems and almost
if you do you can create a list of how
not to solve your problems these people
have it I mean they've done a perfect
job yeah you know what's amazing to me
also is that I never mean to go this
deep into it even I really wanted to
focus more on atheism oh and I'm happy
and we're gonna go there now and yeah
I'm happy to do this but what I think is
particularly fascinating about this is
that everything else that we talked
about and that we're going to talk about
is so related to this that's why this
this whole situation has been so bananas
because this schism has exposed
something that I think people didn't
really realize but let's let's just
leave that portion there unless you want
to give me a closing statement on that
behind atheism no it is fine I just
think that we this is not a very hopeful
time right now you know I mean we're
dealing with very serious ecological
issues and we have people who are
apologists for big oil companies and
denial us and you know denying through
Jenica warming and again I actually do
think those people should be given a
seat at the adult table and anybody who
has a view different from my own as long
as they provide evidence is welcome to
have a conversation I I think that
there's something that's morally
damaging about what the regressives are
doing and I think people have had enough
yeah I have had way more than enough and
and I think now like your your show has
really caused this catalyst almost this
cascade of people who also feel the same
way and they're like minds are
gravitating and they've really robbed us
of any idea of hope that we have because
we look at the the presidential campaign
and I it's just holy moly yeah I mean I
look at the Republicans and I think wow
like any one of those people would be an
unmitigated disaster